all right guys
bang bang super excited to have this
conversation with joe here so thanks so
much for uh for coming on and uh doing
this
it's a pleasure anthony great to be here
yeah um let's just get started with uh
with your background obviously you guys
are working on some very cutting edge uh
medical and technology related uh
products but
what did you do beforehand to us really
get started
uh down this path well my background
to understand how i got to this point to
you know build quantity
uh together with my amazing team is
that i come from a very medical and
bioscience family so i was born to you
know
my parents were both bio-scientists very
passionate
microbiology and other life science
related things
not in business just science um and yeah
i grew up in the lab basically with my
dad and
learned about pcr machines when i was
two
without really understanding anything
but i kind of saw it
and then when it came down to uh
choosing my you know college
uh course um what i would study i
actually wanted to get out of that i
thought like a medicine i've seen that
enough for 19 years of my life i
like it it's cool but i don't know what
else to learn here
and so i basically decided let's become
an economist i was very interested in
business and also economics and so that
led me down a
kind of more the business path i went
into
kind of strategy consulting then murders
and acquisitions and a little finance
then quantitative finance and i found my
passion for everything quantitative
complex systems but especially fuzzy you
know probabilistic systems which are
important in finance
and in venture capital um and then it
came full circle when a family member
who's also a doctor and bioscientist
asked me for advice
on a big math and statistics problem
in genomics for cancer related things
and that was in 2014 and i really got
sucked into that i was at that time
working on a
kind of quantitative venture capital
framework with a slight focus also on by
on life sciences on the investment side
but that project kind of really
triggered my
interest because the deeper i dug into
that question how can you
profile dna not fragments but whole
genomes and kind of dnase from isolated
potential tumor cells how could you
determine if something is a tumor cell
if you just look at the dna
um which seemed like a trivial question
back then but the more i dug into it the
more i realized this is a very
complicated question
um and i asked a bunch of friends at you
know berkeley and stanford and
all kinds of institutions where i knew
they know a lot of things
and none of them could answer the
question and then we had some good ideas
and they said well
that's definitely not something anyone
has done so far
and we kind of solved the very important
math statistics question and genomics
and that triggered basically the
foundation of the creation of quantine
because i realized well if you can solve
that problem and no one has solved it we
can detect cancer
at early stages in the blood because
then we had the tools to basically
identify
specific locations on the genome
necessary to
detect cancer comprehensively in the
blood
so maybe let's go deep into the science
here because i think a lot of people
listening um they recognize that they
don't understand the science nearly as
well as you do
so help us understand when you're
talking about uh dna
like just what is that to get started
with and then we can maybe talk about
how certain cells are mutated or kind of
die
through disease and how uh disease
really kind of runs through the body and
what that does to the bloodstream and to
those dna cells
sure so as a first step i think it's
always important to see what cancer
detection
and cancer is today right it's an
enormous problem 600 000 people die
every single year in the united
united states alone of cancer 1.6
million get diagnosed with cancer
each of us has a 40 lifetime chance of
getting cancer
that's pretty severe um and the 10 over
10
chance of dying of cancer so it's
probably one of the largest risk
each of us has and early detection of
cancer is a
huge game changer if you look at
survival statistics
the difference between for example
breast cancer detected in stage 1 versus
stage 4
is very massive 99 of women have a
five-year plus survival
at stage one nine percent survival at
stage four
so it's a massive difference you know
what your chances are because if it's
detected early
you just go into a hospital get surgery
and you're cancer-free in many cases
whereas if it's like a or it's terrible
it's an ordeal that goes on years and
years of chemotherapy and
very bad outcomes so you wanted to
detect it early
now genomics is something that was not
used or is still not really used in
in cancer detection it is something
where we do hereditary testing more and
more which means we look at your healthy
genome
right so all your cells have a genome a
dna
and that is kind of the building blocks
of life are proteins and the proteins
are encoded in the dna
so the dna is being read out turned into
proteins and we have like
roughly 20 000 proteins in the human
body different ones
and that determines who you are now
that is called hereditary you know
genetics
so all your cells have the same dna we
can look at that dna very easily
nowadays and then tell you if you have
certain predispositions
right if you have certain variants that
other people don't have you might be
more protected or less protected against
certain cancers
so that's the first step of genetics
into cancer that we can tell you if you
have for example brc
a1 variants specific ones and
as a woman your your chance of breast
cancer is much much higher that you get
that over your lifetime
because something in your cell and
metabolism is less likely to
protect you and how do we find those
variances right so like
we know that now if you have that
variance you have a higher probability
of getting breast cancer for a woman for
example
but how are those discovered
you mean how we scientifically discover
the initial insight that there is a
problem or how do we find it in your
body
uh the initial insight that that is a um
an indicator yeah so there are multiple
ways of doing that there's a
mechanistic way where you basically
identify a variant
and then you try to find out what that
actually does right
um so you can see okay if that variant
is on the dna
how does the protein change right and
you can say well if the protein changes
and that protein for example is a tumor
suppressor gene
um like tp53 and it's being
changed then it's a loss of function
effect for example then the protein
stops working
and if that protein is designed to kill
a cell if it becomes a tumor cell
right like a guard that is in the cell
waiting for something to go wrong
and that god becomes disabled then we
know okay that will probably
lead to cancer there are lots of other
examples like there are tons of things
that you can
do that's one way of figuring it out
another way is population health
studies where you have busy association
studies so you look at
millions or thousands of people and you
see well
in the subgroup of people who have that
variant breast cancer is
a hundred times more prevalent like
often it's not a hundred
it's ten times or something um and that
then it's more you know correlation
versus causation no one knows
exactly what's going on but you derive
from that well
probably bad news if you have that
variant we don't know exactly what it
does
um but you're in that new bucket and we
see that people in that bucket have a
hundred
three hundred a thousand percent more uh
chance of developing a disease so you
should be cautious and be on the watch
out
got it and really what this gets at is
something i find fascinating personally
which is just
we really don't understand the human
body that well right
we understand a lot but it is such a
complex
um machine that we're still learning
things every single day and and so we're
kind of doing the best we can with the
information we have right
and that's exactly why we built quantine
and serenity our kind of
patient-facing brand i think there's a
big misconception about science and
medicine
and multiple misconceptions but one of
the biggest one is that we know a lot
like first of all that's always a dumb
assumption we don't even know like we
know
we don't know a lot about anything um
physics or chemistry this is all like
we always scraping the surface if we are
lucky but in biology it's especially
extreme i think when you are in that
field like every single time you
go below the surface and you say oh this
you know causes cancer or something and
then you dig deeper into the protein and
the protein change
the number of proteins we actually
understand what they do in cancer
is probably maximum a handful probably
more one or three like k res or
you know tp53 or something
i mean even there it's very unclear all
the details are extremely unclear
and then you dig one layer deeper and
you have only questions and no answers
and you know every good scientist would
tell you well we simply don't know
like you have to run a bunch of
experiments once you run the experiments
you probably still don't know and you
only have some statistical probabilistic
insight
and i think that's very important in
medicine it's very different from
for example building rockets right
anything that's
kind of artificially created by humans
we have a much better understanding of
if you build a computer or a rocket you
have a pretty
comprehensive understanding because you
build it everything that's naturally
occurring you have just no clue like
when you look at the body
if you're lucky you know like 0.01 of
what's actually going on
and it's very clear you know the deeper
you dig they're just
vast areas of unknowns yeah and so would
it be fair to say that in a lot of
uh the work you guys are doing uh
obviously there's one trying to solve
some of this but but two just in the
broader
uh science and health industry is that
uh we're really focused on just trying
to understand what's going on
right right the the solutions only come
after we understand and so
that is really kind of the the base
layer
and a lot of this biotechnology and
things that are uh being seen as
breakthroughs
really it's just identifying something
that's been going on in humans for
you know thousands of years we're just
now starting to understand given the
technologies that we have
absolutely and i think there's a huge
paradigm shift going on in medicine
right now
very slowly going on so that's why we
created a company to accelerate that but
the paradigm shift is the medicine of
the past and the current medicine
the way of doing medicine is it's very
static right you go to med school you
learn a bunch of things and you think
you know something
which is a big mistake and
i think the new paradigm in medicine
that you know serenity and quantity
stand for is that it's a much more
dynamic system
that is an equation of basically three
things data
you need a lot of data you need
intelligence you need to make sense of
the data
and then action or systems right you
need to then take some form of action
and have some kind of infrastructure to
do treatments or more diagnostics
that's not how medicine works right now
medicine right now static knowledge
you're like if that
then do that whereas you know i give you
one example if you do a conventional
blood test
psa for example for prostate specific
antigen
you get one number it says oh seven
and they say oh it's above the threshold
i might have a problem maybe not
um when we run a test on you
especially the the somatic mutational
test for cancer detection
um which we didn't get into yet that's a
different thing we're not looking at
your
healthy genome um we get six billion
data points
so we get six billion individual
nucleotide reads
out of that example and then we have a
very complicated
cloud-based you know software and ai
system that makes sense of that data
and we are building bayesian layers on
top of that to take in all additional
information around you
and that system isn't perfect but it
gives you an idea
you know what we are dealing with here
that system changes every week
like on on a deeper level because it
learns uh from patients and studies
um it gives us literally six billion
times more
data points than a normal sample
and it's operated on a different medical
paradigm
and the medical paradigm is more data is
always better and more intelligence
and maybe you as someone who's in tech
and business you think like why is that
like a thing like isn't that obvious
like of course more data and more but in
medicine you know the majority of
physicians would
say no that's not true more data is
always
often bad because more data means i may
have to make decisions that i don't want
to make
because if that test comes back positive
i have to do some things
according to standard of care therefore
i would prefer not to do the test
and for non-medical professionals it
sounds absurd especially for tech and
finance like how is this
makes any sense but it's about standard
procedures
it's about liabilities if i don't see it
i can't do anything wrong
and that sounds ridiculous maybe to you
and many listeners but it's literally
what most doctors would tell you
like no if that's a young patient don't
do their tests because if it comes back
positive i have to do all these things
and that would be wrong to do because
it's a young patient
and then you would argue but if you know
it's wrong to do why do you do it it's
like well because it's standard
procedure and i don't want to get into
trouble if you know
that's so let's just not measure
anything
it's absolutely wild how the healthcare
system works
it's it is wild and it's it's especially
wild because you meet so many dedicated
people who are
high iq super trained and knowledgeable
that do all these stupid things
and know they are stupid and see i know
it's stupid that's why i don't want to
do it
so it's this absurd system where we have
so much talent and intelligence
that is kind of yeah in chains they
can't like they can't do what they
should and want to do and that's why
it's so important to break out and build
companies that
don't have to adhere to these you know
standard procedures but can really
strongly innovate with the patient
interest in time
yeah and so let's talk a little bit uh
about
deep genomic sequencing right so i think
that's a term that
at least genomic sequencing people have
heard before they
everything from high level just like
what that is
all the way to they get to um things
around uh genomic editing and kind of
all the scary stuff in most people's
minds
uh so maybe you can just start off with
just like what is
deep genomic sequencing um and then we
can start to talk about like once that's
done
all of the different applications of
that information
yes and that's exactly where the rubber
hits the road so what i
explained before hereditary testing that
is the old school sequencing that still
hasn't reached most of medicine by the
way so old school i mean
five years ago it's still still only
penetrated probably five percent of
medicine
so we need to do that that's very
important but what that does is it looks
at your healthy genome
and to do that on a technical level um
you know you're sequencing something
with
you know a depth of 10 to 30x so what
does it mean
it means if you have a dna strand
and you have a specific location you
want to take
you know 10 dnas and look at
specifically that location
and then you build an average and say
it's a t t t
t g a t
right so on the same location across 10
of these and then you say well an
average is a t
so you have a t right so it accounts for
some sequencing errors so you do it 10
times maybe you do it 30 times
that's how you normally sequence your
cells um you basically sample
a random 10 to 30 dna copies and look at
the same location
30 times and tell you the average and
say well anthony you have a t here
and that makes you regular or it makes
you different
whatever it is now what
deep genomics is and crunching is the
global leader in precision sequencing so
we have the most
precise sequencing technology that can
do the following
if you have a blood sample and you have
let's say 2 000
copies of dna in that blood sample of
cell 3 dna
so 2 000 copies that stem from 2 000
different cells
in your body that died and shed their
dna into the blood
our technology can make sure with a very
high level of
confidence that we can investigate every
single copy
so instead of picking 30 randomly out
and tell you what the average is we can
tell you well we sequenced
all 2000 individual copies and for each
of these copies we can say this is a t
this is the t this is a t but here's a g
and here's a t and so on and what that
allows you to do that's a total game
changer
it allows you to say if there's any
single copy in there
from a cell that carried a somatic
mutation
so a somatic mutation is a mutation that
is not normal for your body
that's not your healthy dna it is
something where a body cell
that you have is mutated has changed
very different from a hereditary variant
so it might be that if you have blue
eyes or green eyes or something
you have a g where other people have a t
on that location but all your cells have
that
that's why it's you um whereas what we
are doing is we want to identify
of all the dna selfie dna in a sample is
there a single copy
that stems from a single tumor cell
right and and that gives you a level of
precision
that is completely paradigm shifting
because before in cancer detection
you have protein tests they need
literally millions or billions of
proteins
in that sample to see any kind of delta
right if you have a psa of seven versus
one i can't tell you the exact number
but we are talking about
millions to billions of of actual psa
proteins
you need to have in there to see that
difference would it be fair to say
um as you're looking at the uh the blood
of uh of an individual would it be fair
to say that
you're grabbing the dna cells out of
that blood and when you're looking if
you're only using a sample so let's say
10 or 30 or 50 or whatever the number is
you could actually miss one of the
mutated cells because it doesn't end up
being in your
random sample so by actually um
sequencing
all of them you're not only one becoming
more accurate but two it sounds like
this precision technology you have
actually lets you test every single one
of them right so it's kind of the
precision leads to higher degrees of
accuracy
exactly so it's very simple the math is
simple if you have
um a tumor in your body early stage
right that tumor at stage one has a
hundred to two hundred million cells
that's a stage one tumor that's
somewhere in your body
out of these cells a certain number dies
every day actually a very significant
number
right so if you have 200 million at
least two to three million actually
turnover per day
so they shed their dna into your blood
if you take 20
milliliters of your blood that's uh
roughly
you know 0.4 of your blood
so it's not non-trivial right it's
nearly half a percent of your entire
blood if you take too big
and so you can ask the question if you
know you have
let's say to be conservative a million
of these tumor cells die every single
day
and shed their dna into the blood
because it gets digested so you have to
divide it by 24 hours and then see how
much is actually
circulating at every minute but you
still if you do the math you still get
to a point where it's very likely that
you have 10
20 30 uh circulating two more dna copies
in
in one tube um so for us
but you have thousands and thousands of
other cells in the tube
of cell free dna that no messes this up
so if you would randomly pick out
you know 10 copies that's not enough
you are very likely to miss anything in
there
if it's at that concentration so you
have to make sure that you look at
everything in that tube and that is
something
even five years ago that sounded like
complete science fiction
um reap five years ago already
anticipated you know where sequencing
will be now so we knew it's definitely
possible
as we started developing everything so
we can do it now
um but 10 years ago i think 95
of scientists would have said that's
complete science fiction that's like a
warp drive or something
why did they why did they believe that
though right so they
said hey that's science fiction but was
it because
they couldn't actually identify all of
the cells
in the bloodstream was it something
around their ability
to scale the testing of each cell like
why did they actually think that that
was not possible
because 10 years ago
you know you need basically three things
to really make that happen
well four things you need some
improvements or this like
you you need some quantum leap inside
advances in chemistry or in strategy how
you sequence so it was just completely
not possible 10 years ago
but then people found some cool things
out about how you can actually barcode
uh dna so to to reduce errors in
sequencing
that's one important thing that you
needed an invention that we couldn't
have made like someone came up with it
randomly and without that it's not
possible
but it's also a quantitative
infrastructure problem you need
sequencing technologies that are
thousands of times more efficient than
10 years ago and we just happen to have
them now
thanks to illumina and some other
companies you need
massive computing power that 10 years
ago
most bioscientists would have said
that's just not possible to ever get
there
and guess what you know things you know
we have massive improvements in
computing power
we are reading like 200 gigabytes in the
cloud in a cloud system per sample
as opposed to one bit right if you i
mean if you have a psa test and it says
seven
no you need a byte i think for that so
you need one byte
and we we have 200 gigabyte files
so just that delta you know you need
multiple improvements on multiple fronts
that are very massive
and so i mean even in 2015 when we did
the math on that
um the costs for one sample based on the
sequencing technology back then would
have been roughly a million dollars
for example per sample yes
and today you know we are far below a
thousand
yeah and so help me understand now that
you're able to
test uh every single cell that you find
in the blood
uh and do it with um an increased amount
of accuracy
what does that allow you to identify
um or kind of do that for me as a
patient or
an individual um i either one couldn't
get access to before from an information
standpoint
or two can you tell me hey you've got a
higher probability
or you actually have cancer before any
other test can identify like
how do you put this into application now
that you have the technology to do it
so very different from hereditary
testing that just tells you what your
probability is of getting something over
your lifetime
somatic testing tells you if you
currently have a tumor
which is of course vastly more
actionable
so what it does is it creates very
complex
deep genomics patterns so what a pattern
means
is we look at you know multiple tens of
thousands of locations
that we predetermined before so we know
if you look at all of them
we have very good chance of intercepting
any kind of tumor variant
across 15 different cancers um so for
each of these locations we then get
what's called a frequency
right because it's not yes or no it's
like how many
mutated fragments do we find and how
many non-mutated fragments
so we see at that specific location we
have 0.1 percent
carry a cancer-associated mutation in
your blood at the next location 0.56
carry something so that gives you a
two-dimensional pattern
right a deep genomics two-dimensional
pattern and these patterns code for
diseases
of course the question is for what
diseases and how do they code for it and
that's the big
statistics and you know research
question so what we did is we are
running very large
patient trials we have a 10 000 patient
trial going on right now
15 different cancer types uh and a
control cohort
so of non-diagnosed patients and
what you know you have to build machine
learning around that that is
also hard to build because you have to
do many things differently from
self-driving cars or you know
recommendation engines is just a totally
different
problem you have to build very different
things
and we run you a pattern against the
historic data set
so right we have your unique pattern and
we run that against
all the other patterns like pancreatic
cancer early stage late stage colorectal
cancer early stage late stage and so on
and control patients patients that don't
have cancer but are smokers
patients that are not smokers not cancer
but obese
and so we we basically run that against
all these different cohorts
and get a match back and that match
tells us well anthony
looks most like x and second most like
y and then you have a bayesian layer
above that that basically says well now
we know the genomics match
now we also take into consideration your
age your gender
other background information we have to
put additional probabilistic layers
probability layers on top of it and then
we get a final
call that says well considering all
these things
the system thinks it's most likely
nothing hopefully or it's most likely
red flag for early stage colon cancer
which doesn't mean you have colon cancer
but
it means well there is something now to
watch out and takes potentially some
action
and what's very important for us is you
have to not just develop technology here
you have to think about medical practice
because you can't just give that to a
patient and say okay good luck
you have to say okay what do we do now
and that creates all kinds of
liabilities regulatory issues all kinds
of things
so what we are building is a system that
solves the entire equation for the
patient
so we say well based on all these things
we think you should do a stool test
even though normally you were not
supposed to do that
because you have enough risk here um
that we say if we
do a stool test like poop in a bucket
you know with some genomics test on top
of it
we can rule out colon cancer with a high
probability or rule in right whatever it
is
yeah and so what i'm taking away from
this is there's a couple of different
steps here right so the first
is what i'll call uh just collection of
the raw materials so you have to
actually get the blood or whatever it is
then there's an actual scientific
process that is identifying the cells
and kind of
having that precision technology or
science that you talked about
and then now what you're talking about
is this third step which is really just
data analytics right um it's it's very
kind of high level
it's very large data sets but it's a
sounds like machine learning type
uh problem where you ultimately can say
hey we have confidence that we collected
the samples from the people that we
think we did
we've got confidence that we were able
to use our precision technology to get
accurate identification kind of the the
raw data
that we have we're feeding to the
machine is accurate and then if those
machine learning algorithms and kind of
computers are are
structured correctly they should be
smarter than the average doctor
right and come back and say here is
exactly the path
uh that this person is on based on the
genomic sequencing
and then you guys almost are going to
build like a recommendation engine
after that that then says you should go
get this test or you should go do you
know x y or z
because of the machine learning has
matched you to these
other people and that's where we know
how to make that recommendation do i do
i have that kind of right
yeah i think you got very close there
are two more steps that make this whole
thing
work after that the next step is
clinical algorithms
and you know that is something you
cannot do through a machine learning
system you have to do this
you need a lot of people involved you
need to apply what's called a delphi
method
so you have to ask a lot of experts for
their opinion
and what happens under all these
circumstances right for all these
different cancers how do we what
downstream clinical diagnostics should
we apply
and here you cross the line from science
into medicine which is a very different
thing
so medicine is all about you know who
agrees
who are other people saying the same
thing because you're you have to
get to a consensus among experts
otherwise you're screwed
right you need liability out of the way
you need to implement that
so it is a very different field than
just science the scientists can just say
well i think this is the best solution
because here's my statistics
in clinical reality you have to say but
who are the people who
agree with that because it's a much more
holistic problem
and then the last step so fourth is
clinical algorithms that
this whole thing needs to work with
which is very complex that's one of the
main reasons why
smart tech guys who go into biotech
often fail because they
lack know the understanding of what goes
beyond science and engineering
what goes into this weird clinical space
you know this authority and doctors and
experts and legal and compliance
but you have to solve that otherwise you
don't have a product
and the final step is of course the
business model
like who actually pays for that and that
again sounds maybe trivial to most tech
and finance guys like why is this i mean
if you save people's lives they just pay
for it
guess what not in medicine so or
well we changed the head fundamentally
but uh
it gets insanely complicated how do you
convince a
insurance bureaucrat that he likes that
and if you show that you save people
like sorry to be so frank but they don't
care
that's not their job you have to show
them that they save money
and you have to show them that you save
money immediately or
quickly over time you know
and then you know things get insanely
complicated and
that kills also most of the innovation
so if you don't
solve four and five all your amazing
tech
is not gonna work because you can't
finance it
and so this this is like the now i gave
you the full picture and complexity why
it's
absolutely non-trivial to truly
understand your business model to
innovate on that front
and to be highly synced with the medical
and clinical reality of things
and then nailed the tech and then you're
getting somewhere
yeah it no it's absolutely nuts and i
guess part of that clinical
side um when i hear the word clinical i
think of
uh all sorts of different tests that can
be run with this genomic sequencing
stuff
uh is this only being done on humans was
it previously done on
animals and then that's where the
technology kind of was perfected and now
it's being brought to the human side
like what is the relationship there
uh in some of that testing to uh
non-human
um kind of clinical trials or whatever
you could do there
well the problem is or the advantage of
genomic sequencing is you don't have to
do a lot of animal trials because there
is no risk in just collecting the
evidence
right so you that was very human driven
from the outset on
uh craig venter and the human genome
project
so you can sequence you know a lot
and you don't you know without any kind
of approval because if you do clinical
trials you just sequence
no one gets hurt as long as there's no
feedback loop um
so it's very different the the actual
sequencing and developing sequencing
technologies you're free to you know
test this on humans because
you're not putting anyone at risk
especially if there's no feedback of
information
once it gets into cancer screening of
course the
game completely changes and that's the
problem that's what's holding the little
biopsy industry back
so what we discuss is called liquid
biopsy because it's liquid and kind of a
biopsy
and that's where we innovated a lot to
actually get out of that problem
and and get medical advancements and
technologies to
our members much faster than we normally
would be able to do that
if we just go through medicare and you
know commercial insurance
got it and then i guess as you um
get better and better at this right
because part of the machine learning
algorithms that are actually analyzing
all of the sequencing
they should improve over time right it's
kind of the beauty of machine learning
help me understand uh is that something
where let's say i'm testing for
a variation that we believe could uh
lead to a higher propensity for cancer
right can i use the uh the advances
and the accuracy that we've determined
on that test uh
in those machine learning algorithms to
then apply to a different type of test
like is there some uh shared knowledge
or
shared analysis that can be moved from
test to test
or is each one of these tests when you
go to start them
they're really starting from scratch
right so you have to rewrite the
algorithms
and and kind of start all over again
without any of that shared knowledge
i mean it's one of the i'm super excited
about these things because it's
probably the most challenging and
rewarding
data science problems i've ever seen um
well there are some in finders that are
also pretty immediately rewarding but i
mean in a human sense
um and you can view it as like in a way
if you take a step back it's like any
data problem right if you want to
determine something if you want to
figure out if a certain real estate
uh you know offering is like likely to
increase in value over time
you could build a crazy machine learning
thing around it like how many people
look at it where it's listed you know
what the current price is what the stock
market does like you could feed
all that information and how does the
stock market data
relate to that real estate as opposed to
other real estate listings around it
well no one knows you can these are two
different tests right you combine these
test sets
and you know if you have sufficient data
sets you can make them work together
and that's if we test your hereditary uh
if you if you understand your hereditary
variance
and we understand your somatic variants
the somatic variants are also like a
time-based
kind of on a timeline time series
because we do that every year
whereas as you're hereditary we don't
have to do every year because it's not
going to change
so you have very different types of data
sets and so you have to
learn how to make them compatible but
each data set adds a significant amount
of insight
and dimension to the problem
i think there are two major challenges
in medical data sets
the first one is they are often very
heterogeneous so if you have a thousand
or ten thousand patients
the probability that you have the same
data sets for these ten thousand is like
zero
unless you do a super clean clinical
trial
that costs you an immense amount of
money um if this is commercial patients
then i might have your
hereditary genetics but not the next one
next person's i might have you
hereditary neo-somatic and good clinical
records but for the next person i might
only have hereditary and some records
so when you build machine learning
systems it's very important to
account for that right that you sample
the comprehensiveness of data is nearly
impossible to maintain
um and just cutting it down to this to
the data dimensions that
are comprehensive is kind of stupid
because you're losing so much
information
so you need much more fuzzy you know
systems that
allow you to recognize much more things
and you also need to
embrace more you know man machine
hybrids
where you have experts and analysts
sitting in front of these things
and use the machine learning more as a
decision support system
and have these mutual interactions
that's very important in medicine
and then the ultimate problem of course
from a business perspective is
you need to close the business model
loop
in order to even get that information
right you need to figure out how do i
actually make money and create a
business model here
and that's very very hard and i'm very
happy we solved it the way we solved
because for most companies that means
you have to
just do very rigid clinical trials over
a decade
that costs you hundreds of millions of
dollars and are super inflexible
and in the end you have bad data sets
because you missed out on the most
important dimension
we see this with a bunch of our peers
that just don't have the right data sets
how do you guys make money what what is
the business model that you figured out
that works
so we made a very bold step that some
love and some hate um
and we said i'm an economist by trade
right so i love to look into a system
you know and understand why is this not
working and medical innovation
innovation is simply not working if you
see what's
possible in theory and what's happening
there's a huge delta between what could
happen
based on all the tech we have and what
does happen in medicine it's ridiculous
my conviction after looking at this for
like over a decade now
is it all boils down not to the fda not
to the government
regulations that's smaller obstacles
it boils down to the payer problem if
you have socialized medicine which we
effectively have or bureaucratized
medicine
which means if i protect your life
as with a new technology the value i'm
generating
is your value because you value your
life and you know your health and your
family's health
but you're not the payer right or at
least not normally
we change that so if i have to create
value for people but get paid by other
people
i'm i will stop creating value for you
because you're not paying me
i start to creating value for the
insurance company or medicare which is
the same thing
so what do they want they want to
cut costs they want to collect your
premium and pay as little as possible
right and they want to do so on a short
time horizon they're not interested if i
saved them money in 10 years because i
prevented you from having stage four
cancer
and saved you know hundreds of thousands
on your cancer treatment
they asked me if i give you that test
now within three years can you recoup
the test
and of course i can't it's not possible
because
you know if you test 100 people you take
two cancers for these two you save a lot
of money
maybe um but maybe if you wouldn't
detect it maybe they would have
had symptoms only four years down the
road so they're off the
you know table for insurance companies
so
you know once we address only the payers
interest
the patient is out of the picture no one
is going to innovate anything
that saves you a life or protect you
because you're not paying and the payer
is not interested in that
it sounds very brutal but it's also very
obvious for everyone who knows business
and so what we said is if you want to
build a company that stands for true
medical progress
you can only do that if you have a
self-payer model
you have to get paid by the people you
protect
because if you let other people pay for
it you're not gonna protect them anymore
um and so what we develop is like can we
develop something that is
affordable for most people but still
provides margins
for us that makes us a real business and
so we are like a you know roughly
two hundred dollars a month membership
fee for a once-a-year test so it's 2400
a year
for that deep somatic test it's an 800
one-off fee for the hereditary testing
but that's a once-in-a-life
uh thing you do then we have an
intelligence layer
once we do your genetics testing that
you continuously get updates on any
drugs
that are incompatible with your genome
that
pose a risk to you any other insights we
have
um on an ongoing level that's 20 per
month
ongoing so it's all affordable
um but over time of course we want to
make this cheaper and over time
this allows us to actually build the
patient base and the clinical evidence
to get insurance more and more
on board because we're developing that
evidence over time but
not by raising a billion dollars and do
you know do a 200 000 patient study over
10 years
so it's a little controversial to just
go for sales payers but i
we see two things the market trend is on
our side
because a lot of patients understand
that you have to do that if you want to
get actually advanced medicine
um and second you know
we also see that it's the only way of
doing it
like as a as i said as an economist i
have no illusions about incentive
you know incentives in business if you
get
you just want to save cross you're not
going to save people it's very simple
it's funny how the same capitalistic uh
tendencies that the finance industry has
existed in medicine as well right
i mean yeah to think
oops yeah to think that giant publicly
traded companies
you know pharma insurance and so on
don't think about the bottom line is a
little delusional
and um once you understand the logics of
a
you know they're all it's not that they
are bad people but you know how it works
you have to report your quarterly
profits
you have to show that you grow your
business
same with pharma if your business is to
sell chemotherapy drugs and you make 161
billion dollars a year
as an industry are you really
incentivized to
cure cancer with like vitamin c i'm not
saying that this works but i'm just
saying let's imagine vitamin c would
work
that would be the worst disaster in the
history of pharma that actually works
they would lose 160 billion dollars a
year
and so the incentives are a little
flawed right so no one is gonna
i'm not saying anyone is actively trying
to not cure it but
if i pitch any big you know
pharma company was oh i have this great
idea it costs only 10 bucks to cure
cancer if it works
i need 10 million dollars to do this
trial for a stage one trial
i mean you can be guaranteed that no one
is going to finance it because they say
that that's an absurd proposition to us
yeah it's pretty crazy um the other
thing around
uh genome sequencing that i think a lot
of people
um you know have heard of but they
probably don't understand
is when you get into all of the gene
editing right so whether it's at the
individual cell level or kind of this
dna editing
maybe talk a little bit about um it's
kind of hard for me to see that world
happening if we don't actually
understand first right we kind of have
to understand
the genes and the dna and kind of what's
going on before you could
even think about editing uh but but
there's obviously technologies out there
that people
kind of have heard at a high level and
how do you think about that
as maybe kind of a long term uh path
that the the medical community
is likely to pursue whether it's just
for you know curing diseases
and kind of uh direct you know uh health
applications versus like hey i want to
change the color of my baby's eyes type
stuff
yeah well i think the the extreme depth
of potential knowledge and the lack
thereof in biology
sounds like a daunting problem right so
we don't understand anything how can we
even edit
but i think this immense amount of depth
and complexity
and the lack of knowledge opens the door
also to genius
right you can be very genius by saying
like maybe we don't have to know all
these things maybe we can hack it
like for example if you know a mutation
does some bad stuff
but you have no idea what you just know
in the outcome is bad but we cannot
figure out what it actually does
maybe you don't need to figure that out
maybe you just remove that mutation
through gene editing
and you know maybe you cut it out and
replace it with a healthy
piece of dna so the whole crispr
revolution i think it's
you know often things get overhyped but
crispr is a little bit like the internet
you know everyone said the internet oh
god it's going to change our lives
forever everything is going to change
and it was like oh my god so
obnoxious these people they are over
hyping this but
it was just true i mean it is changing
everything and crispr is very similar
because crispr allows you to
it's kind of crazy when you think about
it it allows you to
in a very targeted way take any specific
segment of the dna
and replace it with any desired fragment
you want to put in it
to the nucleotide you have 3.3 billion
nucleotides on your dna they can
to the single nucleotides say okay at
that specific location
cut it out and inject that sequence
and if you and they can do it in
living organisms they can basically
inject it into you
and it would kind of you know disperse
across your whole body in theory and
replace it in all your cells which is
extremely freaky because it actually
works right
so you could actually change your eye
color in theory
while you're like living and
why even change all kinds of things so
that is extremely freaky of course
there's an you know
enormous amount of things that can go
wrong you're probably going to die if
you want to change your eye
color because some stuff is going to
happen that no one you know
was considering so i wouldn't test it
out at home
but in theory it's only possible and
so we know a lot of things but compared
to what we should know it's basically
zero
but that doesn't mean you can't do
absolutely amazing
or shocking things and uh
of course i'm very you know we are very
focused on disease and keeping people
healthy and
you know not not let them age too fast
um there are many things you could do
but of course you need very
very deep clinical trials for that to
prove safety especially if you start
editing genomes and living humans that's
it's more regulatory issue i mean
scientifically it's definitely extremely
possible and not even that
i mean you can do it today and where do
people get so like let's say i want to
take one of those nucleotides and
i want to replace it right so i've
identified that that one is a bad one
whatever for whatever reason where do i
get the replacement
is that something that i take from
somewhere else in the body
is that something that's like quote
unquote lab grown where does that
replacement one come from in that
scenario
so here you know and these are great
questions because if you go into biotech
and you learn about these things it's
absolutely stunning
you know how hard certain things are
where you think that can't be that hard
and how easy certain things are where
you think this must be completely
impossible
and then someone's like no it costs five
bucks go on the website you get it
and and it's like stunning and
this is one of these things you can
literally say here's my sequence
p-t-a-a-c-g-a-c-g-a or something
right that you i don't know where you
get this from but whatever you do your
research and say i want this little part
of the protein change these amino acids
and so i have you know these 24
nucleotide sequence that i want to
inject here
you can literally go on the website
i'm not going to promote any specific
companies but you can google that
quickly
copy paste your ttacg things in there
take out your credit card and they send
it to you uh two weeks later
no way in a little tube no way
and then you have them and they are
clean they are
you have a few billion of these little
sequences in there and they're all that
sequence
and what are people doing with those
today are they like injecting them
no there's a huge amount of stuff that
where this is used
we do this every day we order them every
day so um
you know you you need them in sequencing
for example for pcr reactions so they're
called
you know these nucleotide sequences are
hugely
you know used all across the board
they're for example used as primers
so we can use them to basically have a
little sequence that reflects another
sequence on the dna and if you put that
into a mix and do some stuff with it
heat it back up and down and put
polymerase in it this enzyme
then these primers will anneal like they
will align to
the complementary the complement on the
dna
and then start reading that out like
whatever comes after
so you can basically say i want to read
out whatever is on the dna
after that sequence that's actually
sequencing so you say okay if you want
to read out that specific part of the
dna what you have to do is a primer
that you synthesize that sits here and
it
aligns here and then the polymerase
enzyme comes here
and starts complementing the rest of the
dna and then that gets put on a
sequencing machine and you read it out
and you see oh yeah this is my primer i
recognized it that's what i designed
and then what comes after is the
sequence that i was looking at
so i can see if you actually have a t
there or a g
it's kind of similar to like in the
movies when they uh they like clap
really loud so they can sync the audio
in the video
right it is kind of very similar yeah
it's the same thing kind of yeah
yeah um before uh before we go to wrap
up
uh you have been a a bitcoin proponent
uh and have a pretty cool story uh about
uh chamoth
who's uh who's obviously come on the
podcast uh maybe tell a little bit just
about like
how uh you discovered bitcoins i think
it was just pretty interesting that uh
yeah you had some very cool people on
the podcast i'm a big fan of chamath i
think he's
uh of course super smart but he's also
outspoken
and he is what a smart investor always
should be and a smart entrepreneur he
has his different
perspectives he thinks in first
principles about certain things of the
world and then
last time same with kathy from art right
also amazing so i met jameson
howard business school that was an event
i didn't go to howard i was
at the conference and i think in 2014
and uh back then i had i had heard of
bitcoin but not really i mean that is
six years ago and he gave this very
you know passionate pitch about bitcoin
and how it's going to change everything
and he
you know he made this i don't know he he
just totally convinced me to get into
bitcoin just with a little bit of money
so i bought a bunch of bitcoins at 800
um because it's how i do my investing
right i
i analyze stuff um but i'm also
um really listening to entrepreneurs and
smart investors where i
on a meta level see okay this guy
knows something he's smart the way he
thinks resonates with me it's the way i
think
but he thinks about different things so
i'm listening to him on these different
things
and that paid off pretty well so thanks
yeah that's an awesome story um before
uh before we wrap up i always ask
two questions and then you get to ask me
one to finish it up but
uh what is the most important book that
you've ever read
well i actually forgot the title
of the book it was in german i'm from
germany so
uh but that book what was actually the
title i know the cover it was black and
had some weird orange shape on it
i read this when i was 10 11 or
something and that book was basically
taking you on a journey
i forgot you have these you know there
are these famous guys in the u.s who do
this similar thing
it takes you on the journey on the
evolutionary journey
from the big bang to us today and
i remember one specific thing in the
book that was kind of a game changer in
my mind
and that was the theory of life right so
the most exciting thing for me is not
how monkeys turn into humans it's like
trivial i mean a monkey is busy a human
or like even the fish turns into
whatever a rat
kind of that's like fine i get it so
but the question is how does this all
start how does something dead
turn into life and you know in this book
that is
he described that in a way that was so
logical
that was shocking how that stuff turned
into life
that basically if you have a bunch of
molecules
randomly assemble proteins right in the
in the
in the soup the beginning soup thing
right in the sea
and you would just put energy and and
light on it so they'd start changing
they mutate randomly
not as life but as just dead matter as
proteins like oh it has a little light
here and it changes like that
um at some point randomly in that soup
a specific protein or substance or
molecule will change in a way
that it will align to other molecules
and replicate itself
and that's just a pure question of
statistics you to that point like of
course at some point that's just a
random trait of the thing
but at the second way it does that guess
what happens to the soup
these molecules will be much more you
know prevalent than all other molecules
because they're the only ones who
replicate
and that's the first step to life that's
what viruses do for example without
so viruses are not alive in case people
didn't know it's not a life form
and and so you know that was for me
stunning because it was exactly that
that magic steps like oh there's dead
stuff stones and there's life
when you look at humans and stones but
when you narrow it down to this one
thing what is actually the
main trait of life to understand well
the only thing that it does
it replicates and you know
and that is purely kevin that's pure
math statistics chemistry it will happen
inevitably because whatever replicates
will be more of
than the other stuff and then it's just
the race who replicates more effectively
who can eat other stuff
who can develop dna then you're off to
the races but that was such a revelation
because it's a purely mathematic
explanation why life is inevitable
i remember the first time and i forget
the name of the book as well but
i read about telomeres and they were
basically talking about uh the
replication
uh and and you're just like wow this is
a whole world that i don't understand i
don't know if i want to learn more
because it's scary
uh but at the same time it helps you
understand life for sure
uh the you spend a lot of time thinking
about uh human life obviously
and kind of what humans are made of and
dna sequencing and all of that
uh what about aliens are you a believer
in aliens not believer
what's the thoughts there um well the
fermi paradox is one of my favorite
topics like why
you know if you do the math on it it's
kind of obvious we should have millions
of asian
civilizations even higher developed
civilizations and
why didn't we meet them it's one of them
you know are they just
lingering out around earth and don't
make contact because we are too
primitive or
what's the thing and i actually i have
this i have my own theory there but i
think
it must be true that there are tons of
civilizations
um but it also is very likely that they
don't go beyond a certain civilizational
development stage
um which allows them to travel
everywhere like quickly
and the question is why so i think these
are kind of first principles how i think
about it there must be all these
civilizations
they must be highly developed and it's
extremely likely that nearly none of
them makes it beyond a certain point
which is a little scary when you think
about it and that point is we are not at
that point it's a point where you can
easily travel everywhere and see
everything which in theory shouldn't be
a problem
right so my theory is
it's a little dark normally i'm very
optimistic but i'm just
reasoning here it's not my opinion i
just reason like what's most likely
and absurdly it has actually something
to do with something very trivial
you would think and that is terrorism i
think
the problem is if you develop as a
civilization
right there is a certain equation like
how much
power does this civilization have have
like the power to change something
and to destroy things it's always the
same thing and of course there's a
totally exponential trajectory
you know if you go on this trajectory
you have a billion times more power in a
thousand years
but that power also applies to each
individual in that civilization right so
if that power is so exponential it's
only a question of time
until you reach a technology point where
every single person in that civilization
becomes capable of destroying the entire
civilization
like it's just a question of time and we
think about atomic weapons and
bioweapons
take this times a billion even if only
10
of the population would be able to
destroy the entire civilization
you turn into that scenario where you
have to rely on
every single human being not to decide
today
to kill everyone and i think that's an
impossible equation at some point
you know if you have a you know a
trillion people
at some point and every single one of
them at every minute could destroy
all others what are the odds that this
never happens like at some point becomes
impossible
and so i think exponential take
and everyone talks about ai in the end i
think that's a much more severe problem
like at some point
your power exponential curve and the
distribution the inevitable distribution
of power leads to a scenario where you
can't survive
listen i don't think that you're very
far off right which is kind of the scary
part of a lot of this and that
um the technology that we have you know
access to as individuals today right
people always talk about you have a
super computer in your pocket compared
to you know the 1950s
or 60s right so that's only you know
what if you kind of look at it's really
60 years of progress seven years of
progress
seems like a lifetime right for for one
human but on the grand scale of
human progress it's a it's a blip so
it's not
okay you just i mean here we are talking
about why these civilizations don't
exist and how they might get
you know extinct if you take nuclear
atomic bombs or hydrogen bombs and
compare them to whatever happened before
what was the biggest weapon before like
some cannon or
machine gun or something in like 18 90.
so then you have an atomic bomb what's
the delta it's pretty severe
and now just go on another 200 years if
that
same leap happens again on a log scale
the next weapon category then
already becomes a little shaky the whole
thing and then
in another 200 years you have another
log scale so you know you have something
that's like
10 million times stronger than like a
big nuke so then you can already like
wipe out the planet and then ai on top
of that so i think it's in everywhere
that you generate more and more these
technologies that are extremely awesome
and powerful
but the margin for error becomes just
slimmer and slimmer
like exponentially slimmer if anything
goes wrong then all of us are gone
and i guarantee you in a thousand years
or two thousand years i mean there's no
way around that
little problem there might be a solution
to the problem but it's a very
complicated solution i assume
yeah for sure um to wrap up you could
ask me one question what uh what one
question do you have
what do you enjoy most about your
podcast and talking to different people
oh
this is the most selfish thing i do i
get to talk to some of the smartest
people in the world and ask them all the
questions that i have
right and yeah i record the
conversations everyone else can listen
but uh but for me it's just i get to
learn um
and by far that's the most rewarding and
enjoyable part of it
is uh you know i learned things today i
learned things yesterday i'll learn
things tomorrow
um and it's pretty cool that uh you know
you would take
an hour out of your time to sit down and
kind of answer questions
and um and teach me things and so i'll
keep doing how did you get into it what
was your first step i'm kind of
interested like how did you
how did you engage on that journey and
what was the main
what were the main obstacles in the
beginning that you faced
yeah um there was a couple of guys who
came to me and said hey you should start
a podcast and
literally i was like well what's a
podcast uh because i thought that i was
listening to pre-recorded radio
uh in the beginning when i would listen
to things like joe rogan
uh whatever um and uh we recorded three
episodes
and uh and we launched it and they were
a huge part of helping me kind of
figure out you know how do you launch a
podcast and all that kind of stuff and
uh there was just enough people who paid
attention to those first three episodes
where i said well maybe i should do a
fourth or a fifth
and then kind of from there it's one of
these things where uh you just kind of
put one foot in front of the other right
and next thing you know you turn around
you're like
oh i've done over 300 of these now like
that's kind of a lot
right and so uh it's been fun and i'll
keep doing it until uh
one day i'm gonna wake up and say all
right no more fun i'm done like i'll
just walk away
i don't know when that's coming but uh
but i don't think anytime soon
awesome yeah thanks a lot for doing that
i always like you know i admire people
who built these podcasts because i
learned a lot from
you know for sure where can we send
people so that they can learn more about
you
and in quant chen um trueserenity.com
our product site so choose serenity.com
uh or directly to quantine.com um
and people can also reach me at jb at
onegene.com if they want to
get in touch directly all right so jb at
quant jen and we'll put uh we'll put
some links in the
in the description for you as well but
listen joe i really appreciate you doing
this this is super fun
i learned a ton and i hope everybody
else does as well
awesome thanks so much anthony i really
appreciate